لم تُظهر إيران بعد أي
إلحاح حقيقي لإبرام اتفاق
ينهي الأزمة النووية الحالية
ويحقق رفع العقوبات الهامة.
تسبب في انهيار jcpoa
في هذا
السيناريو ، سيكون من واجب هذا المجلس
اتخاذ خطوات
حاسمة لضمان عدم قيام إيران بتطوير
أسلحة نووية
واقعية
طالبت جميع العقوبات غير القانونية الإيرانية
بضمانات موضوعية وقابلة للتحقق من الولايات المتحدة
بأن لجنة السياسة النقدية المشتركة (jcpoa) ​​لن يتم نسفها مرة أخرى
بأن الولايات المتحدة لم تنتهك
التزاماتها مرة أخرى وأن العقوبات
لن يتم فرضها تحت
ذريعة أو تسميات أخرى كما حدث
خلال الإدارة الأمريكية السابقة
على  في الجانب الأوروبي ، نحن قلقون من أننا
قد لا نجتاز خط النهاية ،
رسالتنا هي الاستيلاء عليها  هـ هذه الفرصة
لإبرام الصفقة بناءً على النص
الموجود على الطاولة
[موسيقى]
سوبر
[موسيقى
] السفينة التي
كنا صادقين في محادثات الدوحة التي
كانت جادة وإيجابية كما في الماضي
سنكون على اتصال مع
منسق eo  بالنسبة للمرحلة التالية من
المحادثات ،
فإن فريق التفاوض لدينا مستعد للانخراط بشكل
بناء مرة أخرى ليختتم
مع الأمين العام ،
لذلك أحث جمهورية
إيران الإسلامية والولايات المتحدة
على التعبئة بسرعة بنفس الروح
والالتزام لاستئناف التعاون في
ظل JCPOA.